[Music]
one of the most difficult things about
being human is how easily influenced we
are by our childhoods and more
particularly our parents
the human mind between the ages of 1 and
10 is dauntingly receptive infinitely
attuned to its environment
a somewhat cold forbidding father or an
erratic mother really may be all that
are required to breed an elevated degree
of anxiety or self-hatred that colors
the next eight decades
and yet this kind of parental imprinting
is very hard to spot and therefore
overcome
most of us would be highly surprised to
think that a parent or two might be
living inside our heads
the way we think seems to us to be the
result of our own will we seldom come
across any voices or attitudes that feel
actively foreign or externally sourced
nevertheless given how long we were
exposed to them and at what formative
stages our parents may have left more of
a mark on us than we normally recognize
and may be constantly commenting on our
lives from inside like a chorus of
unhelpful marionettes
when we fail a voice inside us may say
you should never get above your station
when a relationship breaks down an inner
voice might whisper never expect
anything from others when a nasty rumor
spreads about us we hear you were always
too impulsive
it can help to ask ourselves a number of
questions about our parents views as
experience has taught us to conceive of
them
we might without thinking too hard and
thereby allowing our defenses to choke
our spontaneous insights finish the
following sentences
my father gave me a feeling that i am a
my mother left me with a sense that i am
a
my father would now think that i am
my mother would now think that i am
what our inner parents have to say is
often not especially enlightened or in
line with what we want for ourselves
and yet we can observe how deeply such
ideas sink into us nevertheless
we can continue the exercise
if i really needed him my father
if i really needed her my mother
to disagree with my mother would mean
to disagree with my father would mean
if i made a mistake my father would
if i made a mistake my mother would
our parents views rarely stick out in
our minds they merge with our own they
lose their identifying labels they
become sides of everyday consciousness
indistinguishable from what we more
broadly want and believe
yet we should try to reverse the process
of absorption and to recover some
distance between ourselves and impulses
and attitudes that may bear no relation
to our healthier aspirations
it's bad enough to suffer it's even
worse to do so at the hands of what we
might as well term with no supernatural
associations a coven of unfriendly
ghosts
one of the trickiest tasks we ever have
to face is that of working out who we
really are this book is designed to help
us create a psychological portrait of
ourselves with the use of some unusual
oblique entertaining and playful prompts
click the link on screen now to find out
more